Here's my final take about movies and TV
in general. And what I'm going to tell
you is based on decades. I'm 52. So when
I I remember when I was young and you'd
watch whatever, let's say the 80s is
when I came of age. I guess I'm born in
73. So I'm a teenager in the mid 80s,
mid to late 80s. And um you know, you'd
watch movies, you'd watch sitcoms, you'd
watch whatever. And we did a lot of
watching TV at that time if uh we didn't
have laptops or computers or internet,
of course. and uh you just watch
whatever's on TV, these sitcoms, which
were supposed to be harmless
entertainment, right? Well, I don't
think that's what they were because what
they did is they normalized certain
kinds of behavior, especially sexual
behavior. So, I remember any kind of
movie or any show I would watch um
especially if it dealts with teenagers,
right? And I was a teenager. All the
teenagers were proflegates. They were
all out to party. They all wanted to
have sex. No one was a virgin. only the
idiots and the losers were virgins,
including women. Okay, now and that was
everything. Now, here's the question.
Was it like that? Because this is what I
thought when I was young. Oh, these
movie makers and directors are just
trying to capture reality. So, they're
making movies based on reality, which
is, oh, that's what teenagers and
whatever do. They're they're all trying
to party and get laid, as it were,
right? Okay. Now, I've come to realize I
don't think that's what it is. I think
that's what they want people to think.
Okay. So, as a young man, if you watch
that and you think that's how people
act, well, you're impressionable. You're
a young man. You're a young woman.
Whatever. You're you're impressionable.
People are impressionable. Guess what's
going to happen? You're going to act
that way. Your friends are going to act
that way and everyone's going to confirm
that narrative. So, it never was really
done that way because, oh, oh, the
writers wanted to capture reality.
rather they wanted you to follow what
they were presenting to you as reality.
Okay. So it was the ultimate sort of
mind job and um I honestly think that's
what it what what it was and what it
continues to be till this point. So
that's why all these movies and series
they're always so sexually depraved much
more than reality. You know, you would
think if they cared about society, you
know what would be good? To enoble us,
to give us something to inspire to, show
us piety, show us um virtue, show us
restraint. But they don't. They all they
do is they show you actually much worse
behavior than you are capable of because
they're trying to drag you down. And I
think that's the that's the whole thing
that I've learned from decades of
watching television, watching things on
the internet, watching these series. Um
they they're trying to convince
impressionable people because most
people are impressionable. All right.
Most young people don't know what
they're doing. If you're a teenager or
or a younger or if you're an adult
actually at this point, you have no
confidence in yourself probably. And
when you see everything around you acts
a certain way because everyone on Tik
Tok and everyone on Instagram and
everyone on X and everyone on the
internet and everyone on everything acts
a certain way. You will actually find
yourself gravitating and acting that way
because you think that's normality.
It's not. It's uh it's what they want
you to it's what they want you to think
and what they want you to condition you
into being. And anyway, this big ramble
and tangent is my way of saying that the
uh the John Hunati, the rising raven,
that's it's it's part of that genre
where, you know, they just introduce
filth and smut and impiiety and atheism.
And it's not because they're capturing
reality because, as I just showed you,
it's not reality. It's completely
complete opposite of what actually
happened historically. But they do it
because they want you to think that is
how people always have been, always will
be and are. And uh if that's what you
think, well, it's going to be easy. It's
going to be um a lot harder to resist
and not succumb to what they want you to
do. And that's the whole project. I
think I hope you see how these little
things all add up and how they have a
massive impact on people's minds. Think
about it. Where do we get our
epistemology? Where do we get our
knowledge? again, especially if you're a
young woman or man or young person when
it's not from reading books.
Yeah, right. It's uh it's from what you
see and what you see is carefully
curated everywhere and it's the same
exact message and it's a lie. And that's
why it's so obvious to someone like me
because I know it's a lie because
history completely and manifestly
contradicts it. So why do they always
and everywhere insist on the exact
opposite? Well, my theory is the reason
the fire
and the rightous name.